Hello everyone
, this is Kanda, the producer of Resident Evil Village.Resident Evil Nikken
released in May 2021
Set in a village full of jerk and madness.
Thank you for making it such a big hit
. Winters expansion, which includes 3 contents that allow you to enjoy the village even more,
and Resident Evil Village gold edition, which is a set with the main story,
will finally be released next month
.
First of all, please see the latest gameplay image.
ana
Added dlc The first content is
the third-
person view of the main story of the Third Person Mall Village, which was requested by many fans.
You can also feel the fear unique to the point
of view.The battle is a play pit that Chilean fans will be familiar with more than the original.In
addition to the gun action that you can enjoy in Tako's re2 and re3, you can also use the limited resources effectively
such as guarding and kicking back at the village.
Let's master it and survive from desperate situations.
A terrifyingly
good and
unrealistic business, etc., demanding the fabric of the nose and
closing in. In
this world, just one damage can be
fatal.
Then that power will be of great help
.
Stop the enemy's movement with power and the 9th victory is the rule.
Defeat the enemy as soon as possible.
Addition of additional stages to the enjoyable The Mercenaries
Playable characters agree with the
new volume of games in Europe and the United States
[Applause]
Post-sexual additional characters such as Lomitre Square Heisenberg are added to the
series  The additional tlc
winters expansion main story
and the additional dlc set Resident Evil
Village gold edition
will be released on October 28th.
Get a Wolf Outfit as a
gift
Make sure to make a reservation In
addition, Resident Evil Village will be available on new
platforms You can also play with
this macbook pro
Resident Evil Village that can be played on a mac will be available in
apple siri now compatible
I was able to express delicate graphics powerfully with
this
game.It can be played not only on macbooks, but
on all macs equipped with m1 chips and m2
chips.Please see the official website for compatible models.
I would like everyone to enjoy the Resident Evil series, so we
have decided to distribute the
Nintendo Switch cloud version this time.
Appeared in a cloud version that can be
played while connected to the Internet Game fans who have never had a village play environment before
can now play
Release dears October 28, 2022 The
additional content introduced this time
winters expansion is
December 2  A trial version that
allows you to check the operation
of the
cloud version is also being distributed.  Introducing a new look
[Music]
The Resident Evil Nikko range we've introduced so far
is at the
Tokyo Game Show 2022 Kakkon booth, and we're exhibiting the
PlayStation vr No. 2
playable.You
can experience the ultimate immersion.  So, if you are visiting
, please visit the Capcom booth
.
Next, I have received a message
from this title that is scheduled to be released next year
.
Thank you for your
time.We are developing Resident Evil for PlayStation
5 and other latest-generation consoles,
but
we have continued to put up a good fight with current-generation consoles.
However
, I would like to inform you that this work will be compatible with PlayStation 4 Oe.In
addition, regarding the latest information on Resident Evil r 4
, we will deliver the Resident Evil Showcase next month.
Now, I hope to be able to provide you with plenty of the latest information and appeal of this work. See
you all
at Resident Evil Securities State.